("Even If It Kills Me"
by Notez Musik)
- [Gary] Getting
close to landing
in New York.
Just finally got a little sleep
on this flight from
London to New York City.
One hour sleep in London
in the 24 hours I was there
was a little tough so got in
four. And the last three hours
I've been pounding
on my email.
Something interesting I've been
thinking about that I'd share
right now which is the notion
of not doing email when you're
actually at home base.
It's funny how little email or
actual do work or what I would
call defensive work, responding
to things that are second or
third or fourth or fifth tier
priority just to get them done,
I tend to save those with the
use of my assistant, Tyler,
for moments like this where
I have down time on the flight.
It's interesting to me that it
takes a long flight for me to
really catch up with something
that I think a lot of
people prioritize.
Just little fun fact, figured
that I'm going daily that
I'd share some of
the small little tactics
that have allowed me to scale.
A lot of people ask for the
details, one of the details is
categorizing what's actually
important and has to be done
right away and pushing the
things that are not as important
further down the line so that
when you're in your day to day
you're able to actually have the
meetings and interact with the
people that are actually
driving your business.
I think there's a huge lack
of understanding that
spec meetings, biz dev
meetings, HR meetings.
They get pushed back
as not valuable time.
Why are you taking this
potentially good meeting when
you've got things to do or let
HR handle that when people are
your most important asset.
Or there's only, you know, do a
favor for a friend who is a real
friend or a real
business partner.
Just think that people don't
prioritize a lot of those things
when they're the actually things
you should be dealing with.
And then when you actually have
down time like on this flight.
On this flight, I'm not meeting
anybody except
maybe my crew here.
And so, that's when I should be
getting to things that I think a
lot of other people prioritize.
We got to get this done.
Eh, it can wait
two or three days.
And so that's what
I just did on the flight.
Now I'm about to land,
head over to
VaynerMedia's office.
Have two important employee
meetings around some
business opportunities.
And then I'm gonna meet
with potentially our first
VaynerSports draft
class 2017 signing
and then AJ and I are
gonna go to the Knicks game.
Been listening to this on
repeat for the last four hours.
(bell dings)
(rap music)
One of the great wastes of
time in my life right now.
Reviewing DailyVees to make sure
one little thing didn't slip in
that might be a coms issue or
leak something or hurt somebody
or hurt something or offend
someone or stir
the pot too much.
I hate it.
- [DRock] Sorry.
- I hate it.
I like the window open.
Feel like I'm a dog.
It's nice.
Global warming is real.
No windows open,
December 2nd in 1984.
100% we're going.
Okay. Cool.
Alright, I'll see
you in a little bit.
Today's gonna be a big day.
This is why DailyVee
is so awesome.
We're signing
our first player
of the 2017 draft class.
And the timing that AJ and I
bought into and bought
Symmetry Sports, this is Vernon
and a bunch of other guys
from Sadat from last year.
We kind of
inherited that process.
This was our first
coast-to-coast process.
This is a really
exciting moment.
This is really our first player
we're signing as a
complete VaynerSports entity.
I met Jaylen in
Tennessee when
I was in Chattanooga.
Were you with me that day?
- [DRock] Nope.
- No.
This is exciting for me.
This is a big moment.
Look how good
New York looks, DRock.
- [DRock] Of course,
there's a wall there.
- [Gary] (laughs) It's
a good lookin' wall.
(DRock laughs)
Bang, mother fucker.
Something good happened.
That's fucking awesome.
That's why you
guys keep me around.
I just landed from London
I'm walking into the
VaynerMedia office.
Just living the dream.
I am, I agree.
Hold on, one second.
What's that?
- Can I take a picture of you?
- [Gary] Sure. What your name?
- I'm Bianca.
- Bianca, I'm Gary.
- I started following
you in Instagram recently.
- Thank you.
- You're very inspirational.
- Do you work here?
- I do, I work at Coach.
Where are you guys going?
- VaynerMedia,
that's my company.
We work here too.
- That makes sense.
- [Gary] I'll probably
see you again.
Have a good weekend.
- [Bianca] Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
Hey.
No, no.
Nope, no I just
love human beings.
I'm just a human
being lover. You?
("Even If It Kills Me"
by Notez Musik)
- [Man] That was
great one over there.
- [Gary] You like them?
I'm gonna put them
on right now then.
'Sup, Bri?
- Long travel day?
- Yeah, I was just in
London five minutes ago.
Yo! What?
- [Tyler] (inaudible)
- [Gary] You need
me for two seconds?
Okay.
Okay, fine.
Fine.
- 9 A.M. start.
- What do I have before that?
It won't go and I feel like
it's because I have drafts.
Until I'm done with the
drafts, would that be possible?
I don't think so because
I thought I got some off.
Hey guys.
That's my intuition.
- 'Sup, my man?
- You know what I mean?
- You got two seconds?
'Cause I know I'm not gonna
catch you before
the end of the year.
- Yeah, I'll have two
seconds, go hang around there.
I'll be back.
- [Woman] Hi.
- [Gary] Hi.
What's going on?
Hey.
- [Paul] I'm Paul.
- [Gary] Paul,
it's such a pleasure.
I'm aware.
Looks so much nicer than
that black and white photo.
Scares, literally given me, that
photo has given me nightmares.
What are you guys doing?
- [Steve] We are
talking about their group.
- Good.
- [Steve] It's kind of the
first one of all of them.
- [Gary] So my big thing is that
I think the creative scope can
be even bigger than
we've been anticipating.
- [Woman 2] I think, we haven't
yet talked about very, very
large but we are basically
trying to set ourselves up for a
third pillar of creatives.
- That's the
entire conversation.
Just so everybody knows.
The entire conversation is to
get as much whatever let's say
(censored) was right and let's
say it ends up being (censored)
my preference would be that's
(censored) million in video
production for...
Basically if you really think
about it for us to
pull off what our ambition is we
just basically have to move the
market to believe that our
three minute and seven seconds,
our 19 second,
our four minute nine second,
our one minute eight second
videos on Facebook
or the alternative to TVZ.
Hi.
- This is Franny, my
youngest daughter.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] It's really
nice to meet you.
How are you?
- [Fran] I'm good.
- [Gary] Good.
Such as pleasure.
- [James] She's off today and
she's thinking about being
a marketing major.
So I said, alright why don't you
come in and I'll show you what
it's like to work in marketing.
- Oh, it's insane.
(Gary laughs)
I've been to five other
companies with my dad,
by far the best one here.
- That would make sense to me.
- She's been to Saatchi,
Instagram, (inaudible), she said
dad this is the best company.
- [Gary] This is
the best one.
(group laughter)
- They were shucking oysters.
- It's also 20 years
younger on average.
- Yeah!
- [Gary] Hey.
- [Tom] 'Sup, dude?
- [Gary] How are you?
- How are you?
I'm Tom. It's nice to
meet you, man.
- [Gary] Tom, real pleasure, man.
Just wanted to say hello.
- Hello.
- [Gary] I didn't
think I was gonna be here.
- Hi, I'm Lisa.
- [Gary] Lisa, how are you?
- Nice to meet you.
- You were in London.
- [Gary] I was in London and
the jet stream did us a favor.
So, I figured I'd say hello.
How are things?
- Yeah, good man.
How are you?
- [Gary] How's it going?
My man!
- [Jalen] 'Sup, 'sup?
- [Gary] How are you?
- [Jalen] Good.
How you doing?
- [Gary] Good to see you.
This is, I'm so pumped.
(group laughter)
I'm not even sure,
I might be just
as excited as you guys.
This is cool.
How are you my man?
Real pleasure.
- [Man on phone] I'm
chillin' absolutely.
- Congratulations.
- [Man on phone] Appreciate it.
I'm saying the same thing.
- Man, this is a big day.
Obviously, we came in you were
already done with
the draft process.
I'm like this is really,
for me this is the first one.
I'm really excited.
We feel really honored.
It feels, it was crazy.
I don't know if you've
been thinking about.
It was so much thinking about
that (censored) meeting today.
- Yeah.
- It's just so crazy.
I don't know.
I feel very blessed and honored
and we're very humbled and
I'm so confident in what value
we're gonna bring here and
I know how different we are.
Heck, I think Jalen might end
up making more money post his
playing career giving public
speeches of being the first guy
that signed with this
new formed Vayner thing.
We're really gonna change it
so we're very humbled you guys
trust us and I just want to
thank all three of you so much.
Go ahead.
I'm pumped!
I'm so excited.
I don't know, this is awesome.
I'm so thankful.
- A little higher up.
- [Gary] We just
signed our first guy.
So pumped.
I'm so pumped.
It's such a big deal.
Alright, alright.
- [AJ] The pitch is,
I already told you, Pat Riley--
- [Gary] Yep.
- [AJ] I already told you,
rings on the table
championship.
When you win the Masters
you get a green jacket.
- [Gary] Yes.
- I'm trying to create something
that's kind of like an iconic--
- [Gary] Yep.
- historical reference to
when you sign with VaynerSports.
- [Gary] Yep.
- When anybody signs
with VaynerSports.
I think the cool thing for Jalen
is he can be the
first one to do it.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- So, I think honestly maybe the
biggest differentiator for us as
an agency is the concept
we want to break this industry.
We're gonna do it different.
We're gonna do different things.
And a real way for us to do
that is to help you do that.
If our players don't break the
mold and break the industry and
break the barriers, they're
not gonna be successful,
we're not gonna be successful.
What we write on it is things
that they have to overcome,
and this is a little bit weird,
but what I did here on this
one was I took direct
verbatim scouting feedback.
And I told you, we got great,
great kid, second to fourth
round, but when you get
feedback it's objective.
Two things that were said,
"but he's dealing with injuries"
with your shoulder,
"size is his biggest issue."
I think you know that
and are aware of that.
So these are the things.
Imagine Russel Wilson had
this thing that said--
- [Gary] So cool.
- too small to play quarterback
in the league, right?
And then what we're gonna
do with this is you're gonna
shatter it, we're gonna keep it,
we're gonna display it at the
office and then we're gonna give
it you when your career is over.
Hopefully, 15, 20
years from now.
- [Jalen] Yeah.
- [Woman] What about him
putting what he thinks?
- [AJ] You know,
we played with that.
We thought about that too.
- [Gary] I think they
could add one thing.
- [AJ] You got room.
- [Gary] You got room.
That's a good idea.
- [AJ] Let me get a Sharpie.
- [Gary] That's a
really good idea.
- [AJ] Break it
right at the middle.
Right in the middle.
- One, two...
(breaking tile)
- [Gary] Yes!
Clean.
(applause)
I am pumped up.
That was fun.
- [DRock] You know
what I said, right?
- [Gary] You coming Monday?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- My man.
You look cool.
- [Andy] Trying.
- Hat, the shave.
You feel cool to me today.
We're not rooting for
the Wolves tonight.
- [Man 3] Definitely getting
on TV with that.
- [DRock] What the hell?
- [Jalen] I'll see
you in the morning.
Hit me up in the morning.
- [Gary] Okay, I will.
- [Jalen] Or tonight.
- [Gary] Okay.
Have a good weekend.
See you later.
Thank you.
'Sup, brother?
How are you?
- [Man 4] How are you?
- [Gary] All well?
- [Man 4] Yeah.
- Me too.
It's on the side.
It's actually the way we go.
Really good.
That was such a high.
When you know you're birthing,
you just saved my life DRock.
Feeling really good.
You know?
First off, quick
little walk to The Garden.
Haven't done this yet so
I'm excited about that.
Oh, DRock, look at that.
They're doing
that, what is that?
- [DRock] What are
you pointing at?
- [Gary] The guy who's drilling.
- [DRock] Yeah, yeah,
yeah, they're welding.
- [Gary] They're welding,
that's what I was looking for.
Welding.
Feeling great, man.
Super excited
about signing Jalen.
He's a great kid.
- [DRock] Tyler, are
you going to the game?
- [Tyler] Yep.
- [Gary] Everybody's
in the building.
Sitting here trying to figure
out what the fuck I'm gonna
do for DailyVee tomorrow.
Not used to doing Saturday.
Family time, so gonna
come up with something.
Maybe Q&amp;A, then we'll film it.
We got to text tonight, DRock.
Going to my sister's tomorrow
for some early Hanukkah stuff.
("Feelz" by BAMF)
Oh!
- [Announcer] The Knicks win.